[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
متطوعون في ادلب يشكون قله المساعدات
وينتقدون تاخر المنظمات الدوليه في
الاستجابه
في هاتايا بتركيا انقذوا ثلاثه اشخاص
بينهم طفل بعد اكثر من 260 ساعه من
الزلزال
لندن تكشف عن تنفيذ ايران ما لا يقل عن 15
محاوله اختطاف او قتل مواطنين بريطانيين
[موسيقى]
طب ثم طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه
النشره الاخباريه من العربيه افادت مصادر
العربيه بان انهيار مبنى فيري في حلب جراء
هزه ارضيه الليله الماضيه مشيره الى وجود
عالقين تحت الانقاض وكان المركز الاورو
متوسطي لرصد الزلازل قال انه تم تسجيل هزه
ارضيه بقوه 5.2 على مقياس ريختر في سواحل
اقليم اسكندرون وهي الهزه التي شعر بها
سكان حلب واللاذقيه وادلب وحماه وحمص
والساحل السوري الى جانب سكان مناطق لبنان
الشماليه
[موسيقى]
احتاج متطوعون في شمال غرب سوريا على قله
المساعدات وضعف الاستجابه من المنظمات
الدوليه بعد الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
المنطقه وقال متطوعون في المناطق التي
تعاني منذ اندلاع الحرب في سوريا وخروجها
من سيطره النظام السوري ان قله المساعدات
تسبب ضررا اضافيا لملايين السوريين
من طالب نحن باغاثه المتضررين والمنكوبين
بهذول بهذه الفاجعه تاخروا عليهم
بالاستجابه الاولى عن نخبرهم لا يتاخروا
عليهم بالاستجابه الثاني الناس حاليا
متضرره جدا بالعراء دون غذاء دون ماوى دون
اي مقومات للعيش هذا البناء يتكلم عن
تخاذل الامم برمته عن مساعده هذا الشعب
كما نقول في كشعب سوري لدينا مثل معروف
الميت لا يوحي ميت ولكن الشعب السوري قد
اثبت العكس واحيا نفسه بنفسه
قال منسق الامم المتحده الاقليمي للشؤون
الانسانيه للازمه السوريه مهند هادي قال
ان المنظمه تواجه صعوبه في عد النازحين
لكثره اعدادهم شمل غربي سوريا
نامل ان لا يرتفع عدد الضحايا كثيرا ولكن
مما نراه ونسمعه لا يمنحنا الدمار الذي
خلفه ذلك الزلزال في الحقيقه الكثير من
الامل في ان تكون هذه نهايه الامر قبل ان
يبدا الزلزال كان هناك حوالي اربعه ملايين
ومائه الف شخص بحاجه الى المساعده في شمال
غرب سوريا كثير منهم نازحون الان ومع
تزايد هذا العدد نجد صعوبه كبيره في تحديد
عدد الاشخاص الذين نزحوا مجددا بسبب
الزلزال لكن يمكنني ان اؤكد لكم ان الامم
المتحده والشركائها يبذلون قصار جهدهم
لتوفير الماوى المؤقت لهؤلاء الاشخاص
بالاضافه الى المساعدات الاخرى المطلوبه
من جهه يتخوف الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر من تفشن
خطير للامراض في سوريا اتحاد المنظمات
الصحيه حذر من انه اذا لم يتم توفير مساكن
دائمه لمهانه لمئات الالاف من النازحين
بسرعه فان التفشي الوبائي امر غير مستبعد
الناس كانوا بالفعل غارقين في الازمه
وبالطبع الزلزال يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه
الوضع الصحي تحت الضغط ايضا نقص الوقود
والتضخم والازمه الاقتصاديه وتاثر النظام
الصحي بشده جراء وباء كوفيد 19 كلها اشياء
تجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه
هلا شويه تاجيل مشان المدرسه نحن هلا
باركين فيها لانه ما عندنا بيوت يعني هلا
صفينا ان احنا بس بالمدارس
نستقر فيها طاول طاوله بدايه نتهبطت يعني
عشان نرجع على البيوت اللي بده يعطونا
اياها عشان نامن الاطفال انه ترجع المدارس
هلا بتتاجر فحوصات شوي يعني الاطفال
احمد حمشو من اهلي قريه بسنيا في مشروع
ادلب في الشمال السوري تلك القريه التي
انهارت فيها عشرات المنازل نتيجه زلزال
المدمر الاثنين الماضي احمد بقي اربعه
وعشرين ساعه تحت الانقاض مع ابنتيه قبل ان
يتم انتشالهم احياء في حين فقد زوجته
وبقيت اطفاله
الم فاطمه اكبر من ان يوصف وذاكرتها طبع
فيها فجر الزلزال الدامي عندما ايقظها
ارتجاف منزلها على اصوات تحطيم ما حولها
جرت فاطمه وشقيقتها الصغرى نحو ابيهما لكن
شده الزلزال تفوقت على الوقت اللازم
للهروب
فتح الباب
فاطمه منحتها الحياه فرصه اخرى مع كسر في
قدمها واختها الاصغر بيان التي اختبات في
حضن ابيها لم تصب باذى فيما اصيب الاب
بكسر في الساق لكن الانقاض ابتلعت الامه
وطفلين اخرين فيما بقيت الطفله الثالثه
ريان في عداد المفقودين ارادت
ليش هيك صار معنا الاب المفجوع وابنتاه في
احد مشافي ادلب البؤس ونظرات الضياع
يكسوان وجه فاطمه مع رفيق قد يطول هو
الصمت ربما لان القصه التي عاشتها تحت
الانقاض من الصعب البوح بها فالقصص تحت
الركام لا تقل قساوه عن تلك التي فوقه بل
ربما هي اشد باسا حنان المصري العربيه
افادت وسائل اعلام التركيه بان فرق
الانقاذ فيها
من انقاذ شابين بعد قضائهما اكثر من 261
ساعه تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
وقبل هذه العمليه بقليله انت شلت فرق
الانقاذ طفلا عمره نحو 12 عاما من تحت
الانقاض في ولايه في ولايه هاتاي وذلك بعد
260 ساعه من الزلزال
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الى ذلك انتشلت فرق ولا انقاذ التركيه
امراه على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاض في
مدينه قهرمان مرعش بعد مرور 258 ساعه على
الزلزال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كما تم اخراج فتاه تبلغ من العمر 17 عاما
من تحت انقاذ مبنى انهار في اقليم قهرمان
مرعش وذلك بعد مرور
248 ساعه على الزلزال
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه
بير جوداليير في تصريحات للعربيه ان سلاح
الجو الفرنسي يشارك في عمليات الانقاذ في
تركيا عبر مقاتلات تابعه له مضيفا ان
الجيوش الفرنسيه تساهم في دعم الجهود
الوطنيه والدوليه لتلبيه دعوه تركيا
للمساعده ولم ياتي المتحدث نفسه على ذكر
سوريا خلافا لما قال الناطق باسم الخارجيه
قبل ايام
الجيوش الفرنسيه استجابت للطلبات التي
قدمها رئيس الجمهوريه لدعم وزاره الداخليه
لناحيه المساهمه في تلبيه دعوه تركيا الى
تقديم المساعده الدوليه وفي هذا السياق
وصلت فرق الانقاذ التي ارسلناها على متن
مقاتلات تابعه لسلاح الجو الفرنسي الى
تركيا فرق الانقاذ كان نصفها من العسكريين
والنصف الاخر من وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه
وقد عمل الجميع في اطار وحدات التدخل
للحمايه المدنيه وبهذه الطريقه فان الجيوش
الفرنسيه تساهم في دعم الجهود الوطنيه
والدوليه لمواجهه هذه الماساه
[موسيقى]
قال يا قائد شرطه مكافحه الارهاب
البريطانيه
ضباطه يتعاملون بشكل متزايد مع تهديدات من
دول معاديه مثل روسيا والصين وايران
وان تلك التهديدات الارهابيه زادت الى
اربعه اضعاف خلال العامين الماضيين كما
قال جوكس ان ايران نفذت ما لا يقل عن خمسه
عشره محاوله اختطاف او قتل مواطنين
بريطانيين مؤكدا على ان مكافحه الارهاب
البريطانيه يجب ان تواجه تلك تهديدات تغير
المسبوقه لهذه الدول المعاديه
داخل ايران اظهرت مقاطع فيديو استمرار
مظاهرات مناهضه للنظام في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه من بينها العاصمه طهران تاتي
هذه المظاهرات تلبيه لدعوات التظاهر
الخميس في عموم انحاء البلاد وهتف
المحتجون بشعارات مناوئه للنظام من بينها
الموت للدكتاتور في اشاره الى المرشد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هكذا رايته مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمنيه
رشاد العليمي انه لا يمكن تحقيق السلام
دون ممارسه اقصى درجات الضغط على ميليشيات
الحوث وايران العلي مشدد خلال لقائه مع
الممثل الاعلى للاتحاد الاوروبي لشؤون
السياسيه جوزيف بوريل في بروكسل شدد على
ضروره تفكيك رؤيه الحوثيين القائمه على
التعبئه العدوانيه ضد دول الجوار
والديانات والحقوق والكرامه الانسانيه
اعلنت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين
جون كيرلي العربيه ان الولايات المتحده
ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجيه عبروا عن
قلقهم البالغ بشان دعم ايران المستمر
للاسلحه التقليديه والصواريخ المتطوره
وانظمه الطائرات دون طيار للحوثيين الذين
اطالوا الصراع في اليمن
عقد كبار المسؤولين من الولايات المتحده
واعضاء مجلس التعاون الخليجي اجتماعا
لمجموعه العمل الخاصه بايران في مقر مجلس
التعاون الخليجي اكدت مجموعه العمل بالامس
على الشراكه طويله الامد بين الولايات
المتحده واعضاء مجلس التعاون الخليجي
وعزمنا المشترك على المساهمه في الامن
والاستقرار الاقليميين وادانت الولايات
المتحده ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
استمرار ايران في سياسه زعزعه الاستقرار
بما في ذلك دعمها للارهاب واستخدام
الصواريخ المتطوره والاسلحه السيبرانيه
وانظمه الطائرات بدون طيار وانتشارها في
المنطقه وحول العالم عربه الولايات
المتحده ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجيه عن
قلقها البالغ بشان تعميق تعاون الجيش
الايراني ثنائي الاتجاه مع الجهات الفاعله
الحكوميه وغير الحكوميه بما في ذلك توفير
ايران المستمر للاسلحه التقليديه
والصواريخ المتطوره الانظمه الطائرات بدون
طيار للحوثيين الذين اطالوا الصراع في
اليمن
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
بشاغا يقول ان ليبيا في خطر ويدعو الى
توحيد مؤسسات الدوله
حياكم الله اختطف مجهولون سته اقباط
مصريين في ليبيا وطلبوا فديه للافراج عنهم
ووفق وسائل الاعلام مقربه من الكنيسه
القبطيه واوضحت المصادر ان الاقباط السته
اختطفوا اثناء توجههم برا من بنغازي الى
طرابلس وان الخاطفين طلبوا فديه تقدر ب 30
الف دولار عن كل فرد
قال رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلف من
البرلمان فتحي باشاغه ان ليبيا في خطر
داعيا الى توحيد مؤسسات الدوله والمضي
قدما نحو الاعمار وانهاء الحروب وقال
بشاغا في كلمه بمناسبه الذكرى الثانيه عشر
للثوره ان الليبيين سيتجاوزون هذه الازمه
بتسخير كافه الامكانات لاجراء الانتخابات
التشريعيه والرئاسيه التي ستنهي الانقسام
وتجدد الشرعيه على حد تعبيره
قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد انه مؤتمنا
مع الحكومه على حقوق الشعب التونسي وعلى
سيادته وسياده الدوله التونسيه دعيا الدول
المنتقده لتونس الى النظر في واقعها اولا
حقوق الشعب التونسي وعلى سياده الشعب
التونسي وعلى سياده الدوله التونسيه
لم نبعث ببرقيات او لم ندلي بتصريحات
تعبر عن انشغالنا باوضاع الحقوق والحريات
في عدد من العواصم التي تصدر منها مثل هذه
البيانات
سيادتنا فوق كل اعتبار
وفكره الحريه
استبطناها قبلهم بكثير
فلينظر في تاريخهم قبل ان ينظروا في
تاريخنا ولينظر في واقعهم قبل ان يتحدثوا
عن الاوضاع في تونس
قال رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في
السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش وافق
على الاتفاق الايطالي ويدعمه عن قناعه
مؤكدا ان الاتفاق يعالج مشاكل السودان
ودعا البرهان قوى الحريه والتغيير الى
ضروره القبول بالجلوس مع القوه السياسيه
الاخرى
[موسيقى]
والله نحن
في الطريق ان احنا ماشيين فيهم
[موسيقى]
احنا
ودعمنا الاتفاق الاطار اللي بتتكلموا
على القناه مسلحه
لانه هذا الاتفاق الايطالي بعد الاجابه
مشاكل السودان نحن عشان المركز بتاع
الحريه والتغيير ولكن الكتله الوطنيه نحن
اللي قلنا عشان السودان والان مع زوج
مع الحريه والتغيير مع الكتله الوطنيه
مع السودان مع السودانيين
عبر البيت الابيض عن انزعاج الاداره
الامريكيه بشده من اعلانه اسرائيل بشان
التوسع في بناء المستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه وقال البيت الابيض ان واشنطن تنظر
بقلق عميق الى قرار مجلس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بالتوسع بنشاطه الاستيطاني في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله والذي يقوض حل
الدولتين
غضب يسود شارع الفلسطيني بعد قيام اسرائيل
باعتقال عدد من الفتيه واتهامهم بالتحريض
على العنف بعد اجراء قناه اسرائيليه
مقابله معهم اضافه الاستمرار اعتداء
القوات الاسرائيليه على الفلسطينيين في
القدس الشرقيه المحتله وتفتيشهم بطريقه
مذله على حسب تعبيرهم
غضب يسود شارع الفلسطيني بعد تفتيش
الحقائب والاجبار على خلع الملابس في
الشارع امام الماره ذل وتنكيل وضرب
واعتقالات واسعه هكذا يصف الفلسطينيون
تعامل الشرطه الاسرائيلي معهم وحتى مع
اطفالهم واعتبروها عقوبات جماعيه وعمليات
انتقاميه وتخويفا بعد تنفيذ عمليات فرديه
من قبل فلسطينيين في القدس الشرقي المحتله
التي اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنين واصابه عدد
منهم شهر يناير فقط كان هناك عندنا في
القدس 255 معتقد 255 معتقل غالبيتهم حوالي
ما فوق 160 معتقل تم اطلاق سراحهم بعد
المحاكمه هذا يدل على ان اسرائيل تنتهج
سياسه ممنهجه وهي الانتقام من كل ما هو
مقدسه يعني هي لا تفرق بين المقدس البالغ
وبين الطفل وفي السي
اعتقلت اسرائيل طفلين لا يتجاوز عمر كل
منهما ال15 عاما بعد استدراجهما للحديث عن
العمليات الفرديه واجراء مقابله معهما من
قبل قناه اسرائيليه علما انه حسب القانون
يمنع بث مقابلات مع قاصرين دون موافقه
ذويهم الصحاف الاسرائيليه تلعب دور في
اصطياد اطفالنا يعني الذي حدث معهم انهم
لم يذهبوا الى الصحافه ولم يطلبوا
المقابله بل اتى اليهم الصحفي تم اسقاطهم
بحسب رايي من قبل الصحافه الاسرائيليه وتم
زجهم بموقف اللي هن لا يعرفون اساسا معنى
الكلام هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يتعاون
فيها الاعلام الاسرائيلي مع الشرطه
الاسرائيليه هناك عشرات الحالات التي تم
فيها اعتقال فلسطينيين اثناء وجودهم في
ساحه المواجهه بعد التعرف على وجوههم من
خلال فيديوهات وصور وفقت من قبل كاميرات
المراسلين الاسرائيليين والذين على ما
يبدو تم تجنيدهم لصالح الشرطه الاسرائيليه
اذا افلت من كاميرات المراقبه العسكريه
التي تنصبها اسرائيل في كل مكان وكاميرات
الاعلام الاسرائيلي لن تفلت من مراقبه
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصه بك فقد
شنت اسرائيل مؤخرا حمله اعتقالات تستند
الى كل ما يتم مداولته في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي من نشر النصي او فيديوهات مصوره
لناشطين فلسطينيين او حتى اراء شخصيه
سياسيه تعتبرها اسرائيل تهديدا لها لا
نقول غاصي من القدس العربيه
اتهمت شركه هولنديه تدعى اي اس ام لصناعه
الرقائق الالكترونيه اتهمت موظفا سابقا
لديها في الصين بسرقه معلومات حول
تقنياتها واضافت شركه الهولنديه انها
ابلغت السلطات في هولندا والولايات
المتحده بالخرق وياتي ذلك بعدما اعلنت
واشنطن طلب تراخيص لشركات المصدره للرقائق
الى الصين فيما طلبت من هولندا واليابان
اتخاذه تدابير مماثله
شهدت فرنسا امس يوما خامسا من الاضرابات
والتظاهر احتجاجا على مشروع لتعديل نظام
التقاعد حيث تريد النقابات من مواصله
الاضراب الضغط على النواب الذين تنتهي
نقاشاتهم المحتدمه لهذا المشروع منتصف يوم
الجمعه
في نهايه النشره هذا تكثير بابرز العناوين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
متطوعون في ادلب يشكون قله المساعدات
وينتقدون تاخر المنظمات الدوليه في
الاستجابه
فيها طريه بتركيا انقذوا ثلاثه اشخاص
بينهم طفل بعد اكثر من 260 ساعه من
الزلزال
لندن تكشف عن تنفيذ ايران ما لا يقل عن 25
محاوله اختطاف او قتل مواطنين بريطانيين
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]